on the crackdown has started
[Applause]
shots are fired in the capital napiedle
[Applause]
as water cannon hoses protesters
[Applause]
you can hear it clearly here
round after round going off
protesters show what they claim was
being fired
this woman is among the injured it's
reported
at least three people have been shot
here
in mandalay pro-democracy protesters are
also targeted
witnesses say police acted without
warning
immediately they increased the full sort
of water cannon
and the people ran away i i
i was so scared
i i'm also ran away i feel smoke smell
and
[Music]
my cheeks my cheek feels they're so hot
and i can breathe well
after four days of peaceful protests
today the authorities
tightened their grip roadblocks
curfews and limits on gatherings the
tactics of military leaders
intent on destroying these
demonstrations
but the people aren't giving in
on state tv tonight the other side
pictures of
officers allegedly injured and verbally
abused
but it's not a simple case of police
against protesters
in magwe several officers suddenly
change
sides seemingly using their shields
to protect the crowd
[Applause]
the battle for myanmar has entered a new
more dangerous
phase final warnings have expired
casualties have been sustained
but the protesters here are determined
defiant unwilling to let go of the
democracy
they've fought so long for siobhan
robbins
sky news